[Musique]
en tout cas je suis content de tomber si
tu as et il paraît qu'il est excellent
ce resto oui je sais je suis déjà venu
une fois
ah ouais avec qui l exil copains
d'accord enfin un ex d'ailleurs tu fais
quoi le week-end prochain jeu le temps
de la disney away j'adore disney avec
pias était trop marrant j'ai dû disney
non c'était la fouille et je voulais
dire parc astérix ouais le parc astérix
est cool aussi
non mais tu peux pas m'en vouloir
d'avoir vécu en te rencontrer moi mais
je sais j'ai les première fois à cette
marque plus que c'est comme ça les
nommés sénat tu m'étonnes non mais en
même temps moi je m'en fous j'en ai
plein d idées
tiens par exemple tu as déjà fait un
bain de minuit oui oui c'est vrai que
c'est pas très originale star a déjà
fait l'amour sur la plage
bon bien avec moi
[Musique]
tu as dû rouler à 300 km heure mon ex il
était pilote avait fait un saut en
parachute
un autre pilote et a déjà infiltré un
gang est vendu de la drogue par amour
ouais leaustic canonsburg huizinga
forever today nager avec des dauphins
c'est bon un plan à trois feuilles a4
fait à 17
le ch'ti canos quesne jean marc c'est
bon j'ai compris qu'on t'a déjà visité
toulon oui tourcoing oui toulouse
oui moscou oui nous y aurons mis du bleu
riz pommes oui paris week marseille le
africaine saint denis non mais c'est
possible c'est une ville que je viens
d'inventer travail rigueur mais aussi
inventé carnet hockey et 1 et en dons
d'organes on a déjà donné un organe fait
mais donner un rein ensuite il est mort
bon et des enfants c'est bien ça fonde
une famille tu l'as pas fait s'ils se
présentent
hicham et jean-louis dit bonjour jean
louis bonjour bon à descendre une pente
à 30 degrés en longboard en faisant
l'amour comme une bête tu l'as pas fait
justement c'est comme ça que ces géants
louis j y
c'est pas important
tu as déjà je sais pas puis ce monde qui
nous entoure pour vivre une autre
réalité un bon t'as déjà vu ton mec
bouffer de la merde lavaud mirent
ensuite rajouté des morceaux de
sangliers faisant d'élément à charge ou
des morceaux de l'hébreu des trucs
dégueulasses
ensuite tu mixes flou tout tu leur aval
on en arrive vaudou des aiguilles
travers son deux corps à tous les deux
ok ça tu vas peut-être déjà fait non
mais j'ai jamais fait et du mini golf
s'est déjà fait du minigolf bon est ce
que tu t'es déjà abonnés à la chaîne
golden moustache
oui 1 est ce que tu as déjà vu une vidéo
qui s'est coupé avant que le mec est
fini sa phrase